Lebanon and Israel or close to resolving
a long-running border dispute in the
gas-rich Mediterranean Sea officials
from both sides say final draft deal
satisfies all their requirements so
let's bring in Bernard Smith in West
Jerusalem Bernard after a long and
sometimes bumpy negotiation Israel is
poised to start exploiting the gas field
in its Waters
yes Cyril Israel has already Engineers
working for the company energian have
started testing the infrastructure the
pipe work that will eventually pump gas
from a karish oil gas field onto Israeli
territory now they think they might be
able to start doing that in about three
weeks time so this deal comes just at
the time when Israel is ready to start
exploiting its field now it hit some
bumps last week when Lebanon made a
couple of uh last minute demands these
were demands about the definition of a
demarcation boys that delineate Israeli
Waters from Lebanese Waters and about
potential Revenue sharing excuse me from
one of the fields that straddles the
Lebanon Israel border but it seems after
intense negotiations meetings between
the U.S mediator both sides have
resolved these final differences and
they can go ahead for a signing ceremony
now it is historic both sides are
calling this deal historic historic
because both countries are technically
at War they have no diplomatic
representation and it's the first time
any sort of agreement between these two
countries has been reached it is also I
should say in Israel's security interest
that this goes ahead because it's in
Israel's interest that Lebanon is able
to exploit any energy resources reserves
it might find in its own territorial
Waters because Lebanon relies heavily on
Iran for energy for oil and for gas and
Israel would like Lebanon to be able to
rely more on its own resources Bernard
Smith reporting live from West Jerusalem
thank you very much let's go to Lebanon
zaina Hodor is waiting for us in Beirut
Zena so do we have an agreement on your
side is that finalized
well we're just waiting for a formality
an official statement from the
presidency the lead negotiator Elias
busab handed that draft text that U.S
mediated draft text to the president and
he spoke to the media afterwards and he
says Lebanon is satisfied our
requirements have been made this is a
good deal a deal that will bring about
economic benefits and really this is one
of the reasons why Lebanon has really
been pushing for a deal along that
Maritime border intermittent
negotiations have been taking place for
years now more than a decade but Lebanon
is in financial crisis if it is able to
start exploring and drilling it could
have revenues from gas production to
help it with with the financial meltdown
but critics argue that you know this is
not the magic wand it will take years
for Lebanon to benefit from those
reserves if in fact there are reserves
because the Kana field that Lebanon took
in the this deal it is still not clear
if it has proven gas reserves but
they're also calling it historic like
Bernard mentioned these are countries in
a state of war with a history of
conflict right now this deal will bring
about economic benefits and security
guarantees for both sides and Zayna
holder live in Beirut thank you very
much